[Musique]
aux moyennes responsabiliser les gens et
puis deux seules de s'engager pour la
ville
[Musique]
fabrique des je t'aime insectes pour les
abeilles et des insectes pour les puces
de niasse a bouté michel gardes
[Musique]
troisième édition la section à la rugby
ds participe aux journées citoyennes
avec cette fois ci m'a dernier
vestiaires wenger
[Musique]
oh
j'ai aimé sa bible c'est participer
c'est pour toujours tout demander à la
mairie est d'être capable de gel au chic
on est capable de donner et grâce à la
mairie aussi parce que même si c'est
nous qui sommes les acteurs c'est aussi
grâce à l'organisation de la mairie
j'ai d'autres choses à plutôt sympa
[Musique]
c'est pour aider les enfants aussi avoir
une activité et des parents à réaliser
les projets des écoliers
[Musique]
ouais
[Applaudissements]